Dr trebuchet's side his wrath fogging up
the visor of his hazmat suit he did a
last-minute spot check making sure he
had his clipboard and Pen then he
reached for the shoebox feeling its
little occupant moving around as he
lifted it up the doctor turned as his
newly appointed assistant researcher
watchel barreled into the room the
researcher was late trebuchet couldn't
even imagine ever being tardy to his
first assignment but the foundation were
insistent on training up their new
recruits as quickly as possible exposure
to a mostly harmless anomaly would in
theory help to normalize some of these
stranger scps that the organization
dealt with Dr trebuchet held back a
cheap shot about watchal being so late
as the assistant researcher hurriedly
clattered into his own hazmat suit both
ready they stepped through the
decontamination airlock after it had
hissed loudly sterilizing the air and
the outer layers of their suits then the
two researchers continued into to the
containment unit even with their hazmat
suits on the differences in temperature
and humidity were instantly noticeable
like the feeling you get stepping off a
plane after a long-haul flight the
cylindrical glass enclosure had been
perfectly climate controlled filled with
Wetland soil and stagnant water it was
like stepping inside a terrarium a tiny
little pocket of swamp large enough for
someone well something to comfortably
live inside that something was scp-811
sometimes known colloquially by her
nickname of the swamp woman however
since bringing her into containment
scp-811 had given herself a different
name which Dr trebuchet used when
addressing the slimy creature a he
greeted causing scp-811 to turn and face
the para Foundation Personnel
she hissed she had shown the capacity
for communication but possessed a
limited vocabulary and struggled with
the proper pronunciation of words Dr
trebuchet clarified he was there to ask
scp-811 questions to which she quickly
responded with a request for food
opening up the shoebox a frog hopped out
which the swamp woman quickly stomped on
and began to eat the dead creature
although while she possessed a mouth she
didn't exactly eat in the sense that we
understand it her body secretes the
slimy mucus that upon contact causes a
rapid rate of decomposition much like a
fly scp-811 will vomit onto things in
order to break them down so she can
digest their nutrients through
absorption she uses this ability both to
hunt and as a defensive countermeasure
against attackers spitting out the waste
of her food that collects in her stomach
grinning at her own efforts scp-811
finished her meal and indicated she was
ready to continue with questioning Dr
trebuchet handed his clipboard to
researcher watchel so that he could
conduct the interview as part of his
on-the-job training what is the earliest
thing you can can remember watch last
reading from the board are we is thing
scp-811 echoed conveying that she didn't
fully understand watto stammered Unsure
how to rephrase early things Dr
trebuchet interjected things before
before box I seem to be understanding
indicating her containment chamber
before before box trebuchet confirmed
appearing thoughtful for a moment
scp-811 asked most before Dr trebuchet
nodded vigorously telling her yes even
though the foundation had mandated this
interview he genuinely wanted to know
how she had become like this immediately
scp-811 gave sweeping demonstrative
gestures with her hands and described in
very vague levels of detail a man a man
who had been taller than a herself at a
time when she was also much much smaller
was like man she said pointing at her
own arm what was like him Dr trebuchet
probed trying to clarify what she meant
in response a pinched her mottled green
skin it surface slicked with mucus this
not like a like man like people she
insisted her skin she meant her skin had
used to look human upon hearing the word
skin from the doctor
scp-811 repeated it prodding at her arm
and then smiled she'd learned a new word
when questioned further by Dr trebuchet
while watchful felt increasingly uneasy
nearby the swamp woman pointed to the
inside of her elbow she described what
she had experienced after this tall man
had approached her painstick here cold a
said needle a Dr trebuchet encouraged
her to use the right word certain she
meant she had been injected with
something they're called needles needle
here scp-811 tried to mimic the sounds
of the word before then going on to
explain that she had experienced intense
pain soon after with her hands she
started miming that something had come
out of her mouth red red red was very
hungry he ate man skin like this hearing
her describe even in loose broken
terminology what had happened to her
became too much for assistant researcher
watchful as far as both he and Dr
trebuchet understood what a was telling
them she had been injected with
something while still a child and then
had eaten the person responsible Machel
who had children of his own couldn't
help but imagine the same horrible act
happening to his own kids and the
thought of it made him vomit in his
hazmat suit given her own chosen method
of attacking and dissolving prey scp-811
couldn't help that she interpreted
seeing watchel throwing up as an act of
hostility it alarmed the swamp woman
causing her to hurriedly retreat to a
nearby pool of stagnant water within her
containment chamber refusing to
re-emerge until watchal and Dr trebuchet
had left angered by the assistant
researchers lack of professionalism and
how it had interrupted the most coherent
explanation of scp-811's past Dr
trebuchet filed a dissatisfied note with
the SCP Foundation it read as follows
while I understand the appeal of
training the new blood on something
relatively harmless and as green as they
are could you please throw them at some
other humanoid for a while trying to
actually get things done here had watch
will been able to stomach what he had
heard at scp-811 saying and probably
through more extensive interviews with
the creature trebuchet could have
learned the full extent of how the swamp
woman had come to be she had been able
to give the broad Strokes of it of
course but her descriptive ability was
limited the story had definitely fit
with what the foundation already assumed
to be the case that at some point a had
been human but what they hadn't been
aware of was the actions of this unknown
individual a nameless man or what he had
injected the young girl with in order to
trigger her transformation at any rate
the only explanation the foundation had
was the war word of scp-811 herself it
was vague at best at worst it might not
even have been recalled with any degree
of accuracy she could have been lying if
she had the capacity to lie and the
specifics of who she was before why
someone had injected her and what with
were all still a complete mystery to the
foundation and not just to them either
given her partial comprehension scp-811
had long been suspected to have grown up
as a feral child a youngster abandoned
when there were only a few years of age
rather than as an infant it certainly
seemed to explain her limited
understanding of human language the fact
that she could communicate at all
implied that she had at some point lived
among other humans but hadn't fully
developed before her transformation but
even if she had been able to communicate
at an adult level scp-811 still wouldn't
have given the full story to Dr
trebuchet not because she was keeping
things from him but because she simply
couldn't the trauma of growing up alone
in the swamp being turned into a monster
and everything else that had come before
were all too much for her she had at
some point suffered a mental break her
mind shutting off the full details of
her past as a defense mechanism the
swamp woman had been through far more
and far worse than even she could
remember and unbeknownst to the girl who
would later come to call herself a the
SCP Foundation had been involved it had
all started way back a long time ago and
many many miles away from where it would
eventually lead to the birth of the
swamp woman specifically it began in
Siberia the SCP Foundation had learned
of an infectious skin disease that had
been discovered there by the gru
division P the Russian government's own
anomaly containment organization they
had encountered a virus that was highly
contagious and that would spread on
Direct contact with organic matter the
bad was far from the extent of it this
infection would begin to transform its
home turning them into a horrific fleshy
mutation that would attack any
non-infected life form in an aggressive
attempt to spread the virus further the
foundation called it as cp610 although
the grup troops had a different name for
it roughly translated they called it the
flesh that hates now was only through a
combined effort between the SCP
Foundation and their Russian
counterparts in Gru division P but this
disease was contained to a single
isolated area within Siberia where it
had first been discovered the Russian
government at the time had agreed to
keep the area under their watchful eye
and that anyone who became infected by
scp-610 would be killed immediately of
course nobody had accounted for the one
who would get away a Russian operative a
researcher within grup had become
obsessed with scp-610 since its
Discovery the virus itself was horrific
producing abominable nightmares but it
could transform human physiology in mere
moments producing fleshy creatures that
were almost unrecognizable as people
this scientist began to wonder if this
transformative property of the virus
could somehow be controlled programmed
even then it may well hold the key to
some of the greatest breakthroughs in
medical science he envisioned using it
to grow replacement limbs out of tissue
cells or to trigger the reconstructive
regeneration of bodily damage the
scientists just needed to figure out how
to prevent scp-610 from fully
transforming someone the only problem
was anyone infected with it was killed
so he took it upon himself to sneak into
the isolated area in Siberia where he
could steal a sample of scp-610 from the
body of a recently terminated mutation
and he nearly made it away unscathed the
scientists plans were quickly discovered
by the joint effort between the SCP
Foundation and grup he had been
requesting a sample through the official
channels for months and now he had taken
one to experiment with and gone on the
run with a new identity calling himself
Alec Holland the scientist fled the
foundation Russian agent sent to pursue
him as far as he knew they were trying
to prevent him from carrying out what he
viewed to be a noble Endeavor but the
foundation knew that even if that tiny
sample of scp-610 was able to spread it
could cause a worldwide catastrophe
whilst piloting a small plane Alec was
shot down over the swamplands of
Louisiana by the time Foundation
operatives arrived in the area all they
found was a burning rack little did they
realize Alec had been rescued by locals
who had taken him aboard their fan boat
and rushed him to hospital he would
later leave before his injuries had
fully healed and returned to the side of
the crash to discover something curious
his sample of scp-610 had been
cross-contaminated with the swamp's
stagnant water teeming with algae and
who knows what else Alec was running out
of time he knew that if his wounds
didn't kill him he would soon be
discovered by the foundation and grup
using a syringe he gathered up the
combination of the virus sample that had
mixed with the natural properties of the
swamp there was no way of knowing what
it would do whether it would still
mutate a person or whether the disease's
transformative effect had been altered
but he had to know and he was living on
borrowed time desperate he raced to the
nearest town a tiny community near the
swamp Alec told himself that the first
person he encountered would be his test
subject he had to see what effect this
altered version of the virus would do to
a human being it just so happened that
the first person he encountered was a
little girl named a and he wouldn't live
long enough to see the full extent of
what he was about to turn her into now
go check out SCP-173 origin story how
SCP-173 got to site-19 and scp-053 young
girl for more mysterious anomalies